- She's a British entrepreneur and leader.
She co-founded the
lingerie company, Ultimo,
and the fake tanning company, UTan.
She has an estimated net
worth of 60 million dollars.
She's Michelle Mone, and here are her
top 10 rules for success.
(swoosh)
- I think that I watched all
my friends' moms and dads
getting made redundant and I thought,
I want to be in charge
of a company and I want
to make people's lives
happy instead of always
make them worry at Christmas time.
"Am I going to have a job
to buy toys for my kids?"
And I thought, it doesn't matter,
if you're born
into royalty or you're born into money,
I'm going to show people that
someone from the East End
who hasn't done well at school
can still make something
of their lives.
It doesn't mean to say East End of Glasgow
that you're going to be a drug
dealer, and you're going to be just
no good at anything.
I wanted to show people
that we're all human beings
and it doesn't matter where we're born,
where we're brought up, how much money
your families have got,
you can make something
of your life because you're
in charge of your life.
And I think that's what drives me.
I just think that my mom
and dad brought me up
and taught me to have respect for anyone,
no matter if you're the queen,
or you're emptying the bins,
and everyone is special.
And I think that just
appreciate life and never think
in negative ways because
negative things will happen.
If you want to achieve
something, write down your goals
and if it doesn't work
out, it's your own fault.
And do it!
You've got to do something
that makes you passionate,
that makes you tick, that makes
you get yup in the morning,
that makes you get two hours
sleep at night if you have to,
like I did last night.
But to make sure that
you're doing something
because you only live
once and you will know
what makes you happy
inside and go with that,
and then it's a case of
you've got to put whatever in
that it takes to get it done.
My mom and dad always taught
me when I was growing up
that you treat people that
how you want treated yourself
and I think that's the best
thing that they ever taught me
because I never treat people
people badly and unfairly.
I always treat them with respect
and I think that's how I've got
such a fantastic team round about me.
They really are all
enthusiastic and determined.
If you've got that idea, it's all about
believing in yourself.
First of all if you've got the confidence
and you believe it and
you know in your heart,
I can do this, that's all it really takes.
Then the other things
come, the business plan,
the financing of it, the
idea, where you're going
to manufacture, or if
it's a service that you're
going to provide.
All of these things come
but first of all you've got
to believe in yourself.
You've got to want to do it.
If you don't want to do
it, don't even start it.
You've got to go it and
you've got to approach people.
Don't ever sit there and wait
for someone to come to you
because I tell you it will never happen.
You've got to look for
your own opportunities
and you've got to say
this is what I want to do,
therefore who's your customers,
what markets you want
to go into, who's your competitors,
write down a really strong
business plan as well.
What keeps my feet firmly on the ground,
I have it back in my mind
I could lose all tomorrow
and you never get too big for your boots
and I'm doing this not just for my family
but I'm doing it to help others as well
because I want to help people
who are not so fortunate
as I am in the places
that I was brought up in,
because I know what poverty is.
I've been at one end of
the stick to the other.
I've been there where
you don't have any money
and you don't have a
bath and the rest of it,
and I've been partying on
boats with Richard Branson
and famous singers and actresses
and so you know, i know
what both sides of life are
and I just want to help
others as much as I can.
I think you know, I've
always thought this way,
fail to plan, plan to fail.
I'm always a planner, I always
create lists, I always carry
a book in my bag, what I need
to do today, both personally
and both in business.
And I stay focused on that list and I try
and tick every single
bit off and if I don't
I'm not Superwoman,
I've got three children,
I'm not the best business
woman on the planet
but I just try my best
and if I don't manage
to do everything on the
list then I take it forward
to the next day.
I fight every single day of
business, I'm so determined.
I start new ideas every single week.
And I think what drives
me, don't get me wrong,
money used to drive me
but then when you pass by
some of these goals that
you achieve, it is on
to another level and
it's weird to explain it,
it's hard to explain it but I
think it's a fear of failure
that keeps me going and always
want to make a difference
for my customers, always want
to give them the best fit,
the best quality and I've
just started up Ultimo Beauty,
Ultimo UTan, worked on
new tanning products,
no streaks, no smell, it's
launched in Booth's, Debenhams,
House of Fraser, Harvey Nichols, Harrods,
it's launched all over and
I just love the challenge
and try and keep it real.
I do my best to keep it real.
Because you know what,
there are other bigger boats
in the sea, much bigger than me.
And I still believe that
I've not made it yet.
I don't believe I've made it yet.
I always had a dream and my
dream was to be big in business.
And I always, always believe
that it doesn't matter
where you're from, it doesn't matter
what background you have,
it doesn't matter education.
You've got to try your best.
But my situation it wasn't for me.
When I left school at 15 with a dream,
and I always, always think big.
You should always think big in life.
Never ever think that
you can't make it because
others out there are better than you.
You're just as good as anyone else.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Twiggy Monae asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Michelle's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe
and I'll see yous soon.
(swoosh)